[Música]
levante la mano quien conozca a un niño
que quiere ser presidente
yo llegué a pensar que si es que había a
lo mejor en un futuro les iba a dar pena
decirlo
busque en google niños que quieren ser
presidentes primeros resultados la
confesión de un niño de 11 años que ya
no quiere ser presidente argentina de
bajo ninguno de los cinco niños quiere
ser presidente españa luego pensé a la
mujer es un tema de hispanos latinos así
que teclee soy rehén tehuantepec para
ser en
hasta arriba hasta de tussam sixteen
eleccions kitson want to be para ser en
washington post' debajo kit save the
police sting para pintarse de cnn ahora
en méxico no es muy diferente según una
encuesta de adecco en la que se preguntó
qué quieren ser de grande la mayoría
contestó al 25% que quiere ser profesor
doctor el 10% profesor 10% ingenieros 9%
pero el ingeniero 7% veterinario
ahora compare con otros países con
españa eeuu japón
y había varias coincidencias profesor se
repetían bastante que creen que apareció
por primera vez ser youtuber
pero lo que era una constante es que no
aparecía ser presidente o trabajar para
su gobierno
les platico como llegué a esta idea
a mí me invitaron a hablar de energía
bajo la premisa que tuve la encomienda
de reabrir la oficina de representación
de la secretaria de energía en la
embajada en washington y fue testigo del
reconocimiento de político desde
expertos en política energética de todo
el mundo sobre el modelo energético al
cual aplaudían basado en pesos y
contrapesos que permitió la competencia
bajo una coyuntura muy particular en la
relación bilateral
antes obama siete embajadores el tlcan
ahora cualquiera de los que estuvieron
detrás de la implementación de la
reforma
uno de los siete embajadores o incluso
el negociador del tlcan estaría antes
que yo para hablar de eso así que usted
por hablar de algo que solo es mío y es
lo que siento al trabajar por méxico a
través del gobierno
la primera pregunta que me hice
que me hizo tener esta idea es me
pregunte qué fue lo que me hizo
llegar a estar representando una
secretaria de estado en eeuu 18 años
después del primer de mi primer trabajo
en gobierno y más allá de lo que una
estudia de ir escalando de jefe
departamentos director director de área
sin duda de ser parte de un equipo y que
lidere ese pique ese equipo te impulse
más allá de todo eso yo se lo atribuyo y
yo sí quería trabajar en gobierno yo
decía que quería ser político sin saber
realmente lo que eso significaba pero
desde el niño construye en ese sentido
ahora bien es claro que hoy en día pocos
niños o si es que hay aspiran a ser
presidente y yo recuerdo en mi
generación se había quien quería ser
presidente o trabajar en gobierno y
platicaba se comentaba sobre estudiar en
la escuela o en tal profesión porque
parecía que es el camino que funcionaba
qué pasó o que no pasó yo veo dos cosas
número uno vende más la nota negativa
los excesos sobre los logros en un
contexto en el mundo donde hoy la
información se esparce a través de redes
sociales y basta con tener un celular
el binomio internet
y
teléfono
han modificado no solo la manera de
interactuar sino de hacer política de
cómo la vemos y de cómo lo informamos
hoy en día en méxico ocho de cada diez
mexicanos tienen un celular inteligente
estamos hablando de 80 puntos 7 millones
en un país donde más del 60% tiene
acceso a internet ahora yo recuerdo
cuando yo estudiaba primaria secundaria
pues no solamente no había celulares el
primer acercamiento a una computadora
era una de este tamaño la manera de
guardar la información era de un soft
bidis ni siquiera chiquito el que es
grande plástico que conectaba a internet
a través del cable de la del teléfono
ahora si le sumas al avance de la
tecnología lo que se divulga en redes
sociales sobre los gobernantes ahí está
la respuesta de por qué no es atractivo
para un niño para una adolescente
dedicarse a esto y en gobernadores en
mexico
la imagen que más se repetía es la que
aparece en varios y en las que hay entre
16 17 gobernadores o que están prófugos
o que están en la cárcel o que están
sujetos del proceso después escribí
alcaldes y me da la opción para terminar
la frase asesinados en méxico
posteriormente escribir funcionarios
públicos en méxico y me da la opción de
terminar corruptos en méjico o
sancionados en mexico
sí bien
esos excesos al desprestigiado y
devaluado al político salpican al
funcionario y si hay una historia de
excesos de impunidad
pero también hay otra historia y voy a
mi segundo punto
esta historia es una historia menos
divulgada sería mejor menos atractiva
en la que luz
protagonistas son 5 millones de
mexicanos 5 millones de mexicanos que se
integran por ese un millón y medio que
trabajan en actuación pública federal 2
millones de cientos que trabajan en
administraciones públicas estatales
sumados con ampliaciones municipales
poder judicial etcétera mexicanos que
hacen que el gobierno funcione el día a
día los que están detrás de la talacha
ya sea en una ventanilla o
redactando una política pública
ahora consulte con mis colegas que
llevan décadas en esto
porque decidieron trabajar en esto y la
respuesta no fue homogénea hubo quien
decía o porque sus papás trabajaron en
gobierno porque cuando eras egresado
trápaga va mejor el sector público que
el sector privado otros porque tenían
mayores semejanzas a lo que habían
estudiado ahora donde si hubo una
coincidencia es en la respuesta de por
qué continuaban trabajando en gobierno y
es porque algo pasó en el camino y es
como cuando te enamoras y no lo ves
venir
y es porque es la respuesta
de lo que hace el equipo al que trabajas
o lo que hace tu jefe oa veces tú
también y esa respuesta es ese
incidencia incidencia en transformar en
tu entorno y eso despierta la pasión
es el proceso de enamoramiento varía
para cada uno hay quien me decía que
inicio cuando vio publicado por primera
vez algo que él redactó y lo vio
publicado en el diario oficial de la
federación otra persona me decía conmigo
inicio en esa primera clase que tuvo en
el instituto matías romero que son las
que informa el cuerpo diplomático en la
que un embajador le decía una vez que
esté sentado detrás de un presentador
con la bandera de méxico difícilmente
vas a querer trabajar representando una
pasta de dientes o una empresa
multinacional
cuando el secretario energía me invita a
integrarme su equipo en 2013 estábamos
discutiendo una reforma la cual fue
aprobada ese mismo año y al llegar a
washington
predominaban las preguntas de si vamos a
poder tener la legislación secundaria en
tiempo o si se iban a poder crear los
entes como la sea
senna cesc enagás cuando llegaban los
tiempos plazos y se cumplía las
preguntas cambiaban ahora eran sobre las
rondas de licitación o sobre las
expectativas porque porque cuando se
estaba diseñando la reforma energética
el barril de petróleo está en 200
dólares y cuando iniciamos las rondas
licitatorias llegó a estar por debajo de
los 30 dólares pero señores los
resultados fueron positivos no solo en
hidrocarburos gracias a las subastas
eléctricas se van a construir 45 nuevas
centrales fotovoltaicas y 20 olivas en
los mejores precios más competitivos del
mundo cómo no me va a apasionar ser
parte de ese equipo
en total
en toda la cadena productiva del sector
se tienen comprometidos 200.000 millones
de dólares de inversión quién sabe
cuánto es eso para ponerlo en
perspectiva con eso alcanzaría para la
construcción del tren maya para la
modernización de las seis refinerías
para la construcción de una nueva
refinería para la construcción de un
aeropuerto el que se ate ex pocos
andalucía o los dos al mismo tiempo y
aún así sobrarían
pero quiero enfatizar que ese modelo
permite compartir el riesgo compartir la
inversión compartir la tecnología y ver
la película completa
los impuestos que se van a causar con
estos doscientos mil dólares es 200 200
mil millones
los empleos que se van a generar
ahora
en el ciudadano lo que quiere es
resultados que se vea reflejado en su
bolsillo
que esté más barata la gasolina pero
aquí pregunto es como transmites el tema
de la temporalidad
por ejemplo una refinería
desde la planeación construcción y
operación estará entre 4 o 5 años según
la práctica internacional
pero también pues que la tendencia es la
electrificación de los vehículos o que
no suma al combate de cambio climático o
retomó por ejemplo uno de los retos de
la reforma energética que es detener el
declive de la producción del petróleo
pero como transmites que para producir
un barril de petróleo en aguas profundas
desde la exploración
pues tardas de entre 5 a 10 años así que
si bien nos vamos a ver el primer barril
de petróleo son 8 años pero solamente
como lo transmite sino que tenga esa
resonancia y aquí es cuando me emociono
como podrán ver y te entusiasma el hecha
es creatividad cómo transmitir
lo que estás convencido que es lo mejor
para el país pero más allá de las
convicciones ideológicas porque puedes
estar de acuerdo en el diagnóstico lo
ideal es que se tomen las decisiones
pero más preparados por los más
capacitados que cuando vayas a votar
dudes por quién por quién pero por qué
no haya varios que te convenzan y no que
votes por el menos peor
ahora
no todo es positivo también hay cosas
negativas nuestro espacio no todo es
emoción pero ideas como sortearlo tenes
burocracia tienes una grilla pero lo que
hace que te mantengas lo que hace que te
hierva la sangre es ese acto ese acto
que incide como poder llevar la
electricidad a ese 1 millón 200 que aún
no tiene que saber que les va a cambiar
su vida
esa vocación se vuelve tu vida se vuelve
tu hobby para mí ni superbowl son los
debates presidenciales para mis series
son los programas de discusión política
mis quinielas son sobre quién va gana la
elección o quién va a quedar como
candidato esta pasión llega y se
incrementa con el tiempo
y llamar a tu país es gratis lo que no
debiera de ser y no puede ser es
trabajar para él si bien el móvil no
debe ser ganar dinero porque si es el
caso no es la opción el salario debe
permitir tener una vida digna pero sobre
todo que vaya de acuerdo a la
responsabilidad y es el funcionario no
nos podemos tomar el riesgo de ahuyentar
a aquellos que tienen esa vocación de
servicio ni de inhibir a los jóvenes que
están contemplando a hacerlos como una
carta como la carrera de vida
somos
120 millones de mexicanos
de los cuales el 30 por ciento tiene
menos de 34 años me dirijo a ellos
a esos 37 millones de niños y jóvenes
a los millennials que son creativas que
son emprendedores que son idealistas
necesitamos es emprendedurismo de esa
creatividad de ese idealismo para sacar
a esos 9 millones de mexicanos que están
en pobreza extrema o para dejar de estar
en los primeros lugares de los países
con mayor impunidad a los post
millennials que son prácticamente unos
nativos digitales sobre informados
autodidactas tienen los atributos para
innovar para visualizar esas mecanismos
para que la educación llegue más lejos y
mejorar la calidad así
pudiéramos superar los nueve años de
escolaridad promedio de mexicano y dejar
de estar debajo de la media de la ocde
en lectura ciencias matemáticas a mi
generación la generación x o los baby
boomers de los que aprendí divulguemos
la otra parte de la historia los que son
más porque el reto es mayúsculo no
solamente para dignificar la función
pública sino para idear mecanismos que
sean atractivos a esas generaciones que
quieren libertad y flexibilidad como los
millennials o que quieren estabilidad y
seguridad como los post milenios
le digo yo a mis pasantes la única
diferencia por la cual yo estoy sentado
detrás de este escritorio y el del otro
lado es porque tengo más años porque
estudiado más que tengo más camino
recorrido pero en un futuro nos
impregnamos
y es más podemos estar en un futuro
ahora yo escuchando y tú detrás del
escritorio y lo creo
mi mayor reconocimiento
a los funcionarios mexicanos adopten un
joven 2 varios sean sus mentores
así les darán la oportunidad de
despertar esa pasión por méxico
cuando mañana un niño decida que quiera
ser presidente algo habrá cambiado para
bien ya sea por que permearon las
historias de incidencia o de vocación de
servicio o porque quiere ser como un
hermano mayor que fue arropado bajo lo
la mentoría de un buen funcionario
público porque se dignificó la política
a lo mejor de arriba a abajo y si no
pues empecemos de abajo arriba cual
fuera la razón yo sí quiero un méxico en
el que muchos niños quieran ser
presidente porque así se les va a
despertar esa pasión por transformar a
méxico y aún cuando decida no no no
quedarse en el gobierno esa cosquillita
esa pasión de querer hacer estos países
un mejor lugar desde cualquier trinchera
pasión por la que vale la pena luchar
vivir trabajar pasión por méxico
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]